so one of the things that I believe that
filmmakers help them to sustain in
building an audience as well is to look
at your you have your film product in
your non film product so your film
product would be the genre say like a
horror for an action film or a drama and
then below that is all than all the
elements of the movie that are not
necessarily the movie which would be
like an example one our fantasy girl
betrayal child abuse a female
empowerment and looking at all these non
film elements to then break apart and
see who can I go out to that this
particular aspect of the film would
appeal to wrangle in that audience one
thing that we're doing is we're going to
women's centers here shelters here in
Los Angeles for starting local we've
gone to the downtown Los Angeles Women's
Center to do a fundraising screening for
the movie and their Center and they
specifically deal with women who have
come in off the streets who have
children a lot of them have come and
seen really bad things not just the
horrors of homelessness but also from
their background where they grew up and
so what we did was we went to the
directors of all these centers we gave
them screeners for them to approve to go
out and set up a venue where we can get
the city involved and all their network
of people in addition to ours of course
promoting it as well but I think that
that that's just one aspect that I think
filmmakers need to look at is not just
you know demographic of this is a female
demo between 24 and 36 or 59 but
actually really go who are the people
who are they as people what are the the
sensibilities of that individual how how
does this movie play into that is it
because it's based on a true story well
some people will see it just based
solely on that is it based because it
deals with a girl struggling
financially maybe there's organizations
and groups out there that we can go to
people who are trying to rebuild their
money or their credit you know I'm just
saying to be critical in thinking about
how to break that down the other part
that I think we were touching into and
people talking about self distribution
DIY or filmmaking I think that going
forward what a lot of filmmakers need to
start looking at is self distribution
off of their website the you know the
Crown has always been Netflix Amazon
video on demand or iTunes getting your
filament on all these platforms and it's
great if you can get some money out of
those things but in reality what's going
to happen is the instant availability of
your film like somebody goes to a
festival and you're fortunate enough to
get into a festival and they screen it
and they want to buy it well if you're
not there with DVDs right afterwards
they want to know where they can go and
purchase it or maybe even tell their
friends where they can get it and so if
you're not on all these different
platforms what you've got well you've
got the technology in place today with
max cast where you can upload your film
you can stream it in HD on your site for
a fee and the fee is done through paypal
or there's another merchant as well but
it's two to three bucks you know two to
three dollars to stream your film and
you can put a license on it so it
expires after 72 hours you can only
watch it two times but it's a dollar
basically / excuse me it's a penny per
minute of charge for max Cassidy it's a
dollar there for you and there's a
little bit left for the paypal
transaction but you will know all of
your sales and you will get all that
customer information instantaneously as
the payments are coming in as opposed to
waiting three to six months before you
start seeing the balance sheets and then
trying to go back and go how is that
possible or how but you'll actually
going to know who's watching your film
and you can do it worldwide and it's not
going to tax your server or your website
because it's being hosted elsewhere it's
just bringing it
fans of film is doing this ill melton
who heads up first lens film festival is
doing this for short films where you can
actually take the code and embed it in a
blog or elsewhere and it actually all
tracks back into one account so you can
have bloggers you can have your friends
you can have other people that actually
put your film on their page in this
little code and they go to pay for it
and they can watch it and blows up on
their screen but all of it is going back
into that one account and I think that
that's the future I think that in one
aspect of it for filmmakers you can
control all the rights it's not
exclusive you can enter as many non
exclusive deals then it becomes you know
Netflix and all these other ones are
secondary it's like you know icing on
the cake it's it's gravy but you'll
you'll know right away who's buying your
movie you'll be able to keep those
people involved with you you'll be able
to message them because you can have all
their contact information they're making
a payment there and you roll them into
your next move
you